[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend der
Ersatz des Tages kommt von Emmanuel
macron es sei nicht gut dass Deutschland
sich isoliere sagte der französische
Präsident ein solches Statement zum
Auftakt eines EU-Gipfels darf man wohl
als Wumms bezeichnen um einen Olaf
scholzbegriff zu verwenden es knallt
gerade aber nicht nur zwischen
Frankreich und Deutschland worauf macron
in ungewöhnlicher Schärfe hinweist ist
das viele europäische Länder auf die
Bundesregierung nicht gut zu sprechen
sind vor allem in Süd- und Osteuropa den
deutschen werden Egoismen vorgeworfen
wirtschaftliche Alleingänge und auch mit
dem lange Zeit zögerlichen Auftreten
gegenüber der Ukraine wurde Porzellan
zerschlagen Florian neuhahn berichtet
aus Brüssel
wir wissen will wie hoch so ein Treffen
in Brüssel hängt der muss die Reihe der
Medien anschauen je mehr Gedränge desto
wichtiger der Gipfel heute stehen da so
viele wie lange nicht mehr und reden die
Leute vor den Mikros so deutlich wie
selten auftritt immer Manuel macron
ich stehe hier seit über fünf Jahren und
mache Vorschläge um Fortschritte zu
erzählen und die Einheit zu bewahren es
ist nicht gut wenn sich ein Land
isoliert
ein Land das sich isoliert er meint den
wohl wichtigsten Verbündeten Deutschland
die Fassade verbirgt was da gerade
brodelt die deutsch-französischen
Regierungskonsultationen nächste Woche
geplatzt wichtige Minister seien
plötzlich im Urlaub wichtige
Streitfragen nicht geklärt Deutschland
rette nur sich selbst kaufe Gas für viel
Geld nur für deutsche Speicher blockiere
zugleich gemeinsame Lösungen es sind
Vorwürfe die mehr oder weniger offen
viele hier äußern
der deutschen Regierung dass sie sich
kompromissbereit verhält dass sie
versucht die Sorgen der anderen
Mitgliedsstaaten zu hören und
Kompromisse zu schließen wie wir alle
das tun
making wir hatten schon viele Gipfel wir
haben oft nein gehört vielleicht hören
wir bei diesem Gipfel mal ein Jahr
es ist wie wohl bei manchem
Familientreffen wenn es um die Rechnung
geht schauen sie alle auf den reichen
Onkel nur das Onkel Olaf das erstmal
nicht einsieht
es ist auch so dass wir natürlich gucken
müssen dass wir das was wir entscheiden
so einrichten dass es funktioniert
niemand möchte ja Beschlüsse fassen wo
es hinterher theoretisch gut ist aber
kein Gast gibt er meint zum Beispiel den
europäischen gaspreisdeckel also ein
Höchstpreis auf das Gas das Europa aus
anderen Ländern kauft Deutschland sagt
nein aus Sorge die Gaslieferanten würden
ihre Schiffe dann woanders hinschicken
wo es mehr Geld gibt nächste Idee ein
gemeinsamer europäischer Gaseinkauf war
bisher schon freiwillig möglich nur das
kaum jemand mitgemacht hat zu
verschieben dieses Thema bleibt die ganz
große Idee gemeinsame europäische
Schulden um alle zu retten wie schon in
der corona-krise Deutschland sagt nein
erst müsste man das bisher nicht
genutzte Geld ausgeben
Deutschland sagt gleich dreifach nein
die anderen rufen das ist egoistisch
Scholz lässt das an sich abperlen
wir sind die größten Befürworter von
Europa wir zahlen 26 Prozent des Budgets
und wir entwickeln viele
solidaritätsmechanismen wie schon in der
letzten Krise
Europa habe einen Deutschland Problem so
hieß es heute mancherorts in Brüssel es
hat so viel ist sicher mindestens ein
Energieproblem die Debatte darüber wird
länger dauern als diese Nacht
Brüssel wenn man da heute macron hörte
konnte schon etwas die Luft wegbleiben
also so eine Störung im
deutsch-französischen Verhältnis da muss
doch einiges in letzter Zeit schief
gelaufen sein
also es ist ja mein erster EU-Gipfel in
Brüssel und deswegen habe ich mich
vorsichtshalber noch mal umgehört bei
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die schon viele
Gipfel mitgemacht haben und
normalerweise ist dass das
deutsch-französische Verhältnis wichtig
um Krisen in der EU zu bewältigen nun
kriselt das schon wirklich auf einem
sehr ungewöhnlichen Niveau und das hat
eben macron mit diesem Satz sehr
deutlich gemacht indem er gesagt hat
Olaf Scholz ist isoliert das hat die
Deutschen auch sehr sehr geärgert macron
findet dass die Deutschen sich beim
gaspreisdeckel einfach nicht bewegen und
er hat dann noch eine Gemeinde eine
zweite Gemeinheit hinzugeführt er hat
Olaf stolz wo man weiß dass er sehr auf
Pünktlichkeit Wert liegt 15 Minuten
warten lassen bis man sich getroffen hat
also da ist vieles im Argen aus der
deutschen Delegation hören wir ganz klar
dass man das was macron macht eigentlich
bewertet als Druck aufbauen als
erpressen damit die Deutschen sich
bewegen und da sagt man wer Olaf Scholz
den Bundeskanzler kennt der reagiert auf
Druck eigentlich glaubt im Gegenteil
nicht mit Einlenken sondern mit Härte
also erfahren zwei Züge aufeinander
nämlich der französische und der
deutsche warum ist es denn so schwer da
eine gemeinsame europäische Lösung für
diese gaspreisproblematik zu finden
also geht es wirklich um nationalen
Interessen die deutschen sagen wenn wir
einen Gaspreis festlegen dann ist es das
Problem dass wir dann vielleicht das Gas
nicht bekommen was wir dringend brauchen
für unsere Wirtschaft das Gas wird dann
woanders hin geliefert und das will man
unbedingt vermeiden und die vielen
anderen die Mehrheit in Europa glaubt
wenn man eben keinen Gaspreis festlegt
dann haben sie Schwierigkeit mit den
deutschen mitzuhalten werden von den
deutschen verboten und bekommen kein Gas
deshalb wollen sie ein Gaspreis Deckel
was könnte die Lösung sein das ist noch
nicht ganz klar alle sprechen hier von
einer typisch europäischen Lösung man
will vielleicht ein dynamischen
gaspreisdeckel beschließen das heißt man
liegt für sechs Wochen ein Gaspreis fest
und wenn man merkt dass man dafür nicht
genug Gas kriegt für diesen Preis dann
erhöht man den noch mal das könnte eine
Lösung sein aber das ist nicht sicher ob
das am Ende dieser Nacht rauskommt
Dankeschön Rolf nach Brüssel
das ist derzeit weniger Verständnis gibt
für deutsche Befindlichkeiten und
Bedürfnisse liegt natürlich auch an der
Vergangenheit an der hallstarrigkeit mit
der Berlin trotz aller Warnungen seine
gasgeschäfte mit Russland immer weiter
ausbaute diesen strategischen Fehler hat
man in Berlin ja inzwischen erkannt
allerdings fragen sich in Europa und den
USA viele ob Deutschland nicht dann
anderer Stelle die alten Fehler
wiederholt nämlich gegenüber China
gerade erst haben die deutschen
Geheimdienste nachdrücklich davor
gewarnt unsere kritische Infrastruktur
besser zu schützen anstatt China hier
weiter Tür und Tor zu eröffnen und da
bahnt sich in Berlin gerade der nächste
Koalitionskrach an diesmal zwischen
Kanzler und großen Teilen seines
Kabinetts es geht um den Einstieg
chinesische Investoren den Hamburger
Hafen Diana Zimmermann berichtet
Tor zur Zukunft so nennt sich hamburgs
Hafen gern und Zukunft ohne China das
mag man sich hier nicht vorstellen
längst hängen andere Häfen Hamburg ab
weil sie so die Argumentation
chinesische Reedereien als Anteilseigner
haben und die sorgen für gute Auslastung
deswegen möchte Hamburg 35 Prozent des
Terminals toller Ort an das chinesische
Staatsunternehmen cosco verkaufen gar
nicht toll findet dass der
Justizminister gerade auf USA-Reise
meine persönliche Ansicht ist dass wir
die Fehler die wir in der Beziehung zu
Russland gemacht haben also ein sehr
abhängig zu machen dass wir die nicht im
Verhältnis zu China wiederholen dürfen
und deshalb ist meine generelle
Überzeugung dass China und auch die
chinesische Regierung keine Kontrolle
über kritische Infrastruktur in
Deutschland bekommen sollte
Robert Habeck wollte heute nichts dazu
sagen sein Ministerium aber hatte das
investitionsprüfverfahren auf den Weg
gegeben dass zu dem Schluss kam die
Chinesen sollten den Zuschlag nicht
bekommen weitere fünf Ministerien sehen
das auch so eigentlich hätte die Sache
im Kabinett damit gestoppt werden müssen
das Kanzleramt aber habe den Punkt nicht
auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt so
Recherchen von NDR und WDR und wenn
cosco nicht aufgehalten wird dann findet
der Deal Ende Oktober statt was ist die
Gefahr zum einen haben wir Risiken mit
Blick auf mögliche Spionage
datenabflüsse viel wichtiger scheint mir
und das zeigt der Fall ja jetzt schon
die Möglichkeit der politischen
Einflussnahme auf
Entscheidungsprozesse in der Regierung
der Kanzler scheint den Verkauf
durchdrücken zu wollen ganz auf seiner
Seite ist der erste Bürgermeister von
Hamburg er findet die Idee mit dem
Terminal toller Ort nach wie vor toll
eine Ablehnung der cosco-beteiligung
durch die Bundesregierung ist im
Hinblick auf die Nation Sicherheit und
Unabhängigkeit nicht begründbar sie wäre
eine schwere Belastung für den
Wirtschaftsstandort und eine einseitige
wettbewerbsverzerrende Benachteiligung
Hamburgs gegenüber Rotterdam und
Antwerpen in denen cosco bereits
Terminal Anteile besitzt doch kaum einer
geht hier mit es gibt eine einhellige
Bewertung der Fachministerien dass diese
Beteiligung
von einem chinesischen Unternehmen was
im Zweifelsfall vom Staat angeführt
werden würde
schwierig ist für unsere Souveränität
und Unabhängigkeit und alle in der
Bundesregierung sind angehalten diese
Souveränität zu verteidigen
die Front gegen Scholz ist heute breit
und wütend und mächtig selbst aus seiner
eigenen Partei kommt viel Unverständnis
später Einsicht bei vielen denn
unabhängig ist Deutschland in Bezug auf
China längst nicht mehr noch viel
stärker als ein Russland hängt unser
Wohlstand an chinasmarkt seinen
Produkten seinen Investitionen das gilt
auch für andere der ein Parteienstaat
hat sich strategisch aufgestellt mit
europaweiten Beteiligungen an mehr als
einem Dutzend helfen das weiß auch die
Opposition das ist eine Machtposition
die gesucht wird und entwickelt worden
ist und wenn es zum Konflikt kommt wird
von dieser Macht Gebrauch gemacht
eine neue Machtposition nun also am Tor
zur Zukunft in hamburgshaven der Kanzler
will das wohl nicht verhindern
ja ein großes Thema das wollen wir noch
vertiefen mit unseren Korrespondenten in
Berlin und Peking zunächst zu Theo Koll
könnte aus diesem hafengeschäft so ein
ähnlich großer koalitionsgrad werden
wenn werden wie zuletzt bei der
Atomkraft nur diesmal halt mit anders
verteilten Rollen Kanzler gegen den Rest
ja also jedenfalls ist der Kanzler
zusammen mit dem Hamburger Bürgermeister
recht einsam in der Ampel und auch in
der politischen Beurteilung dass das
alles nicht so schlimm sei alle mit der
Frage befassten Ministerien sind gegen
den Verkauf an China und für viele ist
es seine Art chinesische Parallele zu
denen an Russland verkauften
gasspeichern auch wenn es nur ein
kleiner Teil des Hafens ist damit würden
dennoch Teile von kritischer
Infrastruktur und auch wichtige
logistikeinblicke in chinesische Hände
gegeben über den Hamburger Hafen sollen
soweit ich weiß künftig ja zentrale
Teile unserer Energieversorgung mit
grünem Wasserstoff laufen und wenn es
stimmt was über den jetzt schon
ausgeübten massiven chinesischen
lobbydruck zu hören ist dann stellt sich
wirklich die Frage der eigenen
nationalen Verwundbarkeit selbst bei
einem dann doch relativ überschaubaren
Investment nun gibt es ja so viele
Warnungen vor den Absichten Chinas und
selbst deutsche Geheimdienste schlagen
Alarm wird das denn im Kanzleramt in den
Wind geschlagen
nein das Kanzleramt weiß natürlich ganz
genau wie abhängig Deutschland von China
ist und wie groß die Gefahr ist Chinas
Wirtschaft ist elf Mal so groß wie die
russische und wenn China uns nicht mehr
beliefern würde beispielsweise wegen
Taiwan Sanktionen dann steht hier jede
zweite Produktionsanlage Stille Olaf
Scholz will weg von dieser Abhängigkeit
und hat auch schon auf dem g7-gipfel in
Ellmau ja eine
multipolare Strategie verkündet aber
solange es diesen neuen Markt in der
Welt für die deutsche Wirtschaft nicht
gibt will er das vorhandene natürlich
nicht aufgeben es dürfte interessant
werden wie die künftige china-strategie
aussieht die gerade bei Frau beerburg im
Auswärtigen Amt er arbeitet wird
letztlich geht es dabei auch um die
Frage welchen Preis sind wir als
Gesellschaft bereit zu zahlen für unsere
Unabhängigkeit und auf wie viel
Wohlstand verzichten wir im kleinen
zeigt sich das jetzt im Hamburger Hafen
dann schauen wir uns die chinesischen
Absichten dabei mal näher an mit unserer
Korrespondentin Miriam Steiner in Peking
Miriam warum interessiert man sich in
Peking so sehr für europäische Häfen
kurzfristig geht es ums Geschäft seine
Investitionen die profitabwerfen soll
und das geht darum dass chinesische
Waren im Hamburger Hafen bevorzugt
abgefertigt werden
interessanter ist vielleicht das
langfristige Interesse cosco ist ein
Beispiel für Staatskapitalismus die
Kommunistische Partei hat direkten
Einfluss auf das Unternehmen und deshalb
jetzt nicht nur um die Interessen des
Unternehmens sondern um die Interessen
des chinesischen Staates wir haben schon
gehört China ist beteiligt an mehr als
einem Dutzend europäischer Häfen china
will diesen Markt beherrschen und die
Dominanz ausnutzen als geostrategisches
Instrument wir haben bei den Projekten
der neuen Seidenstraße ja schon
anschaulich gesehen dass China
Wirtschaftsprojekte benutzt um seinen
Einfluss in der Welt auszuweiten und um
sich chinesische Interessen zu vertreten
und die reichen dann von dem Abgreifen
von Know-how bis hin zur Kontrolle
chinesischer Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Übersee
nun könnte man ja sagen okay aber China
ist von uns ja auch dann wirtschaftlich
abhängig aber das hat sich bei Putin ja
auch schon als ein Denkfehler erwiesen
ja in der chinesischen Denkweise ist es
genau andersrum china will sich in
wichtigen Schlüsselindustrien unabhängig
machen das hat der chinesische Präsident
hier den pingen auch hier beim Parteitag
in Peking diese Woche noch mal betont es
geht um die nationale Sicherheit das ist
seine Prämisse beim cosco-deal testet er
auch wie weit ergehen kann er hat
signalisiert dass eine Weigerung
Deutschlands wirtschaftliche
Konsequenzen haben könnte es geht bei
seinen wirtschaftlichen Ambitionen auch
darum sich machtpolitisch Beinfreiheit
zu verschaffen zum Beispiel bei einem
möglichen Angriff Chinas auf Taiwan käme
es ihm gelegen ein großes Druckmittel
gegen den Westen zu haben und da kann
die Kontrolle über europäische Häfen
natürlich helfen aus deutscher
Perspektive mag es also kurzfristig
vielleicht ein gutes Geschäft sein
dieser koskodil aber langfristig kann es
wirklich ein Problem für die nationale
Sicherheit Europas sein
der Chef des deutschen
Verfassungsschutzes Thomas Haldenwang
hat das ja kürzlich so formuliert
spannend ist der Sturm und China ist der
Klimawandel
danke euch beiden nach Peking und Berlin
und dann kommen wir zu einer anderen
großen Nachricht dieses Tages dem
Rücktritt der britischen
Premierministerin was in Großbritannien
politisch los ist kann man vielleicht am
besten mit ein paar Zahlen illustrieren
in den letzten vier Monaten erlebten die
Briten vier verschiedene Finanzminister
drei Innenminister und jetzt bald den
dritten Premierminister wobei noch nicht
klar ist wer lässt Trust nachfolgen wird
sie selbst wird in die Geschichte
eingehen als Regierungschefin mit der
kürzesten Amtszeit gerade mal sechs
Wochen aus London Yassin hairline
wenn irgendjemand das Gefühl beschlichen
haben sollte dass der Rücktritt von
Premierministerin listras nach nur 45
Tagen und der brexit irgendetwas
miteinander zu tun haben könnten
brauchte zur Bestätigung heute nur Frau
Trust genau zuhören
wir hatten die Vision für eine
Wirtschaft mit niedrigen Steuern und
hohem Wachstum mit der wir die Vorteile
des brexit nutzen wollten ich habe
angesichts der bestehenden Situation
aber eingesehen dass ich den Auftrag mit
dem ich von der konservativen Partei
gewählt wurde nicht erfüllen kann
wirtschaftsexperiment ist bekanntlich in
die Hose gegangen die Finanzmärkte
spielt nicht mit und irgendwie scheint
es als wenn die langen Jahre
experimentellen Regierens der
konservativen Partei ihren vorläufigen
Tiefpunkt erreicht haben seitdem
brexit-referendum 2016 ist Trust bereits
der vierte Regierungschef der vorzeitig
abtreten muss
gestern Abend im Parlament kam es sogar
zu Handgreiflichkeiten der Parteifreunde
untereinander ein völlig verzweifelter
Abgeordneter fast das Chaos so zusammen
ich sollte das nicht sagen aber ich
hoffe dass es sich für alle die geholfen
haben dass Trust premier wird gelohnt
hat einmal Minister einmal wichtig sein
am Kabinettstisch Platz nehmen denn der
Schaden den sie unserer Partei zugefügt
haben ist ungemein
nicht nur der Partei dem ganzen Land
über das alle Welt nur noch den Kopf
schüttelt und wieder gleicht Westminster
rund ums Parlament einem Rummelplatz wie
zu besten brexit-debatten Zeiten der
Spott lässt nicht lange auf sich warten
die Zeitung Daily Star hatte eine Wette
laufen wer sich länger hält lässt Trust
oder dieser 65 Cent teure Eisbergsalat
das Ergebnis ist seit heute bekannt man
könnte sich totlachen wenn es nicht so
ernst wäre
[Musik]
ja da fragt man sich natürlich wie
lassen die jetzt weitergehen soll bei
den Tories Andreas stammen in London
steht zwar etwa ein Comeback des Boris
Johnson an
da ist die Gerüchteküche heute quasi
explodiert am Nachmittag als politische
Weggefährten Freunde von Boris Johnson
erklärten der Ex premier liebäugelt mit
einem Comeback doch vor dieses Comeback
haben die Partei Granden vielleicht
nicht ganz unbewusst eine hohe Hürde
gestellt denn wer an diesem Auswahl
Prozess der am Montag beginnt teilnehmen
will der braucht erstmal mehr als 100
von 360 ungefähr tori-abgeordneten die
ihn unterstützen das ist eine hohe Hürde
und viele ja viele parteigranten hoffen
zumindest dass sich die Toys erinnern
wie viel verbrannte Erde Boris Johnson
hinterlassen hat wie viel Chaos dass man
ihn hinter mir aus ten Downing Street
raus zerren musste es brauchte 60
Minister Rücktritte und
Regierungsmitglieder Rücktritte um ihn
wirklich zu überzeugen zu gehen das ist
ein paar Monate her jetzt wird eben
versucht Boris Johnson er weiß es noch
nicht genau ob er kommen wird aus seinem
Urlaub zurückkommen aber was feststeht
ist eben die Hürde ist hoch aber sollte
es schaffen dass das aber aber diese 100
Stimmen zu bekommen und mitzumachen und
vielleicht sogar ins Endspiel zu dann
stimmt die Parteibasis drei Tage lang in
einer Online-Abstimmung bis Freitag ab
und an dieser Parteibasis diesen 180
200.000 Tories da ist dann noch sehr
beliebt er gilt als der brexit-bringer
der große wahltriumvater von 2019 und
dann könnte das Wirklichkeit werden ist
ein langer Weg und man muss auch sagen
die britische Bevölkerung hat bis zu
diesen sechs Wochen listtras gedacht das
eigentlich nichts schlimmer sein kann
als Boys Johnson intendowning Street
Dankeschön nach London und zum Rücktritt
in London jetzt ein Kommentar vom Leiter
des heute-journalsmiese
Demokratie ist try and R Versuch und
Irrtum listras hat es versucht ihre
Fraktion sieht das als Irrtum und hat
die Premierministerin gestürzt das ist
kein Schaden für die Demokratie Putin
und Ski und andere Diktatoren auf der
Welt die mögen sich freudig die Hände
reiben über die vermeintliche Schwäche
von Demokratien sie irren sich gewaltig
denn es ist Stärke von Systemen wie dem
britischen im Urland der Demokratie das
Entscheidungen revidiert werden können
das Fehler eingestanden werden durch die
Macht der Parlamente durch frei gewählte
Abgeordnete wie sehr bräuchte die Welt
eine solche Möglichkeit in Russland oder
China wenn dort echte Volksvertreter
säßen die einen Irrläufer stoppen
könnten natürlich legt der Speed
Rücktritt in London die Probleme
Großbritanniens offen ebenso das
personelle Chaos der Tories die nun
Neuwahlen ermöglichen sollten mit der
schlichten Begründung die
Wirtschaftskrise die zu Putin verschärft
hat wie übrigens auch bei uns die bringt
Regierungen ins Wanken und wie eben
heute auch zu Fall aber die Demokratie
ist stabil so ungemütlich sie manchmal
auch scheint wie sagte Winston Churchill
Demokratie ist die schlechteste aller
Regierungsform abgesehen von all den
anderen Formen die von Zeit zu Zeit
ausprobiert worden sind mit anderen
Worten es gibt keine bessere das sollte
die wahre Botschaft auch dieses Tages
sein
kommentierte jedenfalls wird es nicht
langweilig in Großbritannien und das
heute schon eine Update hält sie dann
nachher gegen 0 Uhr weiter auf dem
Laufenden
eigentlich sollte heute Bundespräsident
Steinmeier die Ukraine besuchen aber er
hat die Reise hier aus
Sicherheitsgründen kurzfristig abgesagt
Steinmeier hat mit silensky heute aber
telefoniert und ihm deutsche Hilfe mit
der Wiederherstellung zerstörter
Infrastruktur versprochen und welche
Folgen die Bombardierungen haben damit
geht es bei dir jetzt weiter Heinz
danach Angaben der ukrainischen
Regierung sind rund 40 Prozent der
Energieinfrastruktur zerstört die
Ukraine muss deshalb massiv Strom sparen
Präsident selensky reifte Bevölkerung
dazu auf den Stromverbrauch auf das
Nötigste zu begrenzen viele kleine
Dörfer wie hier bei krematorisch sind
komplett von der Energieversorgung
abgeschnitten
die folgende ukraine-krieges sind auch
ein Thema einer Konferenz der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten heute und morgen in
Hannover es geht aber etwa um die
Energiekrise und konkrete Entlastungen
vom Bund für morgen werden Gespräche mit
den Ministern Habeck und Lindner
erwartet
wegen der steigenden Energiepreise hat
der Bundestag weitere staatliche
Finanzhilfen bewilligt so erhalten
Rentnerinnen und Rentner Mitte Dezember
eine Pauschale von 300 Euro Wohngeld
Empfänger und unter bestimmten
Voraussetzungen auch Studierende und
Azubis bekommen einen weiteren
Heizkostenzuschuss und der Bundestag hat
ein Finanzpaket zum Ausgleich eines
milliardendefizits bei der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung beschlossen dazu
gehört auch die Möglichkeit eines
höheren Zusatzbeitrags von
durchschnittlich 0,3% Punkten die
Opposition kritisierte das
Gesundheitsminister lauterbach
verteidigte das Gesetz und sagte es
werde das Versprechen eingehalten dass
es keine Leistungskürzungen für
Patienten geben würde
die Bundesnetzagentur sieht Fortschritte
bei der Gasversorgung im Winter dank der
guten Vorsorge in den letzten Monaten
stehen man mittlerweile besser da und
man sehe auch erste Einsparungen beim
Verbrauch erklärte der agenturpräsident
Müller die Gasspeicher sein derzeit mit
mehr als 96 Prozent sehr gut und
schneller als erwartet gefüllt das
Sparziel von mindestens 20 Prozent müsse
weiterhin erreicht werden
Flucht und Vertreibung in der älteren
Generation hierzulande haben dass viele
selbst noch erlebt was es bedeutet die
Heimat zu verlassen wie es sich anfühlt
plötzlich nicht mehr selbstständig zu
sein sondern ständig dankbar für jede
Hilfe sein zu müssen entweder Verwandten
bei denen man unterkommt und deren
Wohnung plötzlich sehr eng wird oder
fremden die einem Unterkünfte stellen
dazu der tägliche Horror über die
Kriegsgräuel in der Heimat mit den
Bildern der Bombardierungen und dann
muss man auch noch erleben wie das
Gebäude in dem man im Ausland
Unterschlupf gefunden hat abbrennt
mutmaßlich durch Brandstiftung
so geschehen jetzt bei bismar in einer
Unterkunft für geflüchtete aus der
Ukraine eine Stadt fällt und Susanne
Seidel berichten
er kann es immer noch nicht fassen
Einrichtungsleiter andre bondatschukshot
völlig entsetzt auf das was bis gestern
noch seine Flüchtlingsunterkunft war
hier unten hatten wir unsere
internet-traum gehabt wo am besten
Internetempfang gab und das haben die
Bewohner besonders Kinder auch für die
Online-Schulung in der Ukraine benutzt
14 Ukrainer darunter vier Kinder und
Jugendliche haben hier gerade erst
Zuflucht vor dem Krieg in ihrer Heimat
gefunden als das Feuer ausbrach hatten
sie kaum Zeit etwas mitzunehmen
also es ist schnell raus sehr viele
haben auch
Reisepässe sonstige Dokumente wichtige
Dokumente die auch vielleicht für die
Ukraine wie ich die sind also drinne
vergessen oder in dem Panik nicht
mitgenommen niemand ist bei dem Brand
verletzt worden alle geflüchteten sind
jetzt in anderen Einrichtungen
untergekommen
Mittwochabend 21 Uhr 20 Uhr geht der
Alarm bei der Feuerwehr ein wie Zunder
brennt das Reetdach der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft lichterloh steigen
die Flammen in den nächtlichen Himmel
der ehemalige Hotelkomplex brennt
komplett nieder Teile des Hauses müssen
wegen Einsturzgefahr abgerissen werden
ich finde es unmöglich gerade mit den
Leuten die hier gelebt haben die wurde
noch mal alles genommen und es geht
einem schon sehr nah mein Mann ist auch
sofort los ob er ob wir Hilfe leisten
müssen ob jemand zu uns nach Hause
kommen kann aber da war alles schon
organisiert die waren hier herzlich
willkommen und wir haben gesammelt wir
haben gefeiert die Kirche hat viel
gemacht der passt so hier an der Ruine
suchen Kriminaltechniker nach Spuren
schnell gehen sie von Brandstiftung aus
denn die Polizei hat derzeit in der
Region mit einer Serie von Bränden zu
tun allerdings ermittelt am
Flüchtlingsheim auch der Staatsschutz
denn die Beamten vermuten hier einen
politischen Hintergrund da sprechen im
Moment zwei Indizien für zum einen ist
es eine
hakenkreuzschmiererei die hier am
vergangenen Montag festgestellt wurde
und zum anderen ist es natürlich der
Brandort hier im Flüchtlingsheim ist zum
Brandort geworden am Nachmittag trifft
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer am
abgebrannten Flüchtlingsheim ein im Fall
Brandstiftung bezeichnet sie die Tat als
menschenverachtend
und die Antwort des Staates ist dann
eine sehr harte wir werden mit allen
Mitteln des Rechtsstaates durchgreifen
die Tat muss verfolgt werden das muss zu
einer schnellen Anklage kommen und dann
auch zu einer Verurteilung auch André
bondachok hofft auf eine schnelle
Aufklärung konkrete Ergebnisse will die
Polizei Anfang nächster Woche liefern
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit dem Blick
auf die Wirtschaft für die Frage wie es
mit der Inflation weitergeht gelten die
Erzeugerpreise als Frühindikator und da
hat der Statistische Bundesamt heute für
September wieder einen deutlichen
Anstieg gemeldet weil er reale wie
ordnen die Statistiker die Entwicklung
ein klar und deutlich das ist nämlich
der höchste Anstieg seit
1949 als diese Daten zum ersten Mal
erhoben wurden ein Riesensprung der
Folgen haben dürfte denn die
Erzeugerpreise sind ja die Preise die
Hersteller im einkaufszahlen also kosten
die Unternehmen etwa für Gas Strom und
Dünger aufbringen müssen und wenn sie so
wie jetzt durch die Decke gehen dann
dürfte es nur eine Frage der Zeit sein
bis diese Preissteigerungen auch bei den
Verbrauchern ankommen die hohen
Produzentenpreise sind damit ein
Alarmsignal für die Entwicklung der
allgemeinen Inflation tatsächlich
steigen die auf Hersteller Ebene die
Preise im Rekordtempo im September um 46
Prozent im Vergleich vor ihr stärkster
Treiber ist mit großem Abstand die
Energie plus 132 Prozent die Industrie
etwa musste mehr als dreieinhalb Mal so
viel für Erdgas bezahlen als im
Vorjahresmonat auf diesen Kosten wird
sie nicht komplett sitzen bleiben können
manche fahren ihre Produktion runter so
rechnet die Pharmabranche für kommendes
Jahr mit deutlich weniger Output weil
sich bei einigen Medikamenten die
Herstellung kaum noch rechnet jetzt
schon werden manche Pillen und Säfte
knapp andere reichen die Kosten weiter
solange die Herstellerpreise so also
weiter anziehen dürfte ein Ende der
hohen Inflationsraten auf sich warten
lassen im Gegenteil viele Volkswirte
glauben das Ende der Fahnenstange ist
noch lange nicht erreicht vielen Dank
der Zentralrat der Juden in Deutschland
hat
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister Özdemir
mit seiner höchsten Auszeichnung dem Leo
beck-preis geehrt der grünen Politiker
sei ein Streiter gegen Fanatismus
Ausgrenzung und Antisemitismus so
Zentralratspräsident Schuster mit
Özdemir erhält laut Zentralrat erstmals
eine Person mit muslimischem Hintergrund
die Auszeichnung
im kommenden Jahr könnten in Deutschland
mehr als 380.000 Kitaplätze fehlen zu
dieser Prognose kommt die Bertelsmann
Stiftung in ihrer aktuellen Studie dabei
zeigt sich ein Gefälle zwischen den
Bundesländern in Ostdeutschland gibt es
einen Bedarf von etwa 21.000
zusätzlichen Plätzen im Westen von
362.000 am größten ist der Mangel in
Nordrhein-Westfalen
um die Nachfrage bundesweit zu decken
müssten 99.000 Erzieherinnen und
Erzieher eingestellt werden
94.000 im Westen und 5000 im Osten
Deutschlands
das von uns gleich geht es bei Maybrit
Illner weiter die mit ihren Gästen
darüber debattiert wie sehr
Energiekreise und Inflation Deutschland
treffen und gegen 0.30 meldet sich dann
also in göktemir mit unserem
heute-update und uns gibt es morgen
wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter heute
Abend ja auf einem ungewöhnlich hohen
Niveau für diese Jahreszeit scheinen
sich die Temperaturen jetzt ja
regelrecht einzupendeln in Frankfurt am
Main erreichen wir in den nächsten Tagen
an die oder sogar über 20 Grad und
selbst im Norden Deutschlands wie in
Hamburg liegen wir nur knapp unter der
20 Grad Marke der Grund ist eben ein
zentrales tief über dem Atlantik das
kaum seine Position bewegt und immer
weiter warme Luft zu uns pumpt und dazu
wird es jetzt auch nass von Südwest nach
Nordost überquert uns da morgen nämlich
ein kleines Randtief und das bringt
schauerartigen Regen mit den gibt es
auch schon in der Nacht im Nord- und im
Südwesten sind auch einzelne Gewitter
möglich im Osten und Südosten regnet es
vorerst noch am wenigsten es wird auch
nicht mehr so kalt wie in der
vergangenen Nacht die Werte sinken auf 6
Grad im Westen bleiben sie teils bei 15
Grad ja und morgen ist es dann im ganzen
Land mild im Nordosten schon deutlich
milder als heute ungewöhnlich hohe Werte
mit 18 bis 20 Grad nur auf Rügen gibt es
13 Grad und im Südwesten sind sogar
wieder Werte über 20 möglich also sehr
mild der Tag morgen aber nass schon am
Vormittag gibt es Schauer im Norden dann
einen etwas trockeneren Streifen aus dem
Südwesten folgt aber dieser neue Schwall
mit teils lang anhaltendem Regen und
kräftigeren Gewittern und die ziehen
dann am Nachmittag über die Mitte und am
Abend auch in den Osten des Landes von
Südwesten lockert es auf dazu gibt es
einen frischen Südwind windig bleiben
auch die nächsten Tage spätestens am
Sonntag ist es für alle etwas trockener
erst am Montag kommen dann wieder neue
Schauer und einzelne Gewitter tschüss